[Music]
welcome to today's presentation which is
titled the tale of flexibility
generalized average for hyper parameter
tuning and pulling it sounds very
mouthful but by the end of this
presentation you should be able to
unpack every single element of this
title and hopefully use it for your own
advantage in your own projects
the idea for this presentation started
when I visited URI URI is here you will
send him in a second in Haifa and we
went to eat some hummus
so well I think we finished the first
person and they all wanted some extra
and we are and we ask ourselves a
question
that's supposedly is a question that is
too basic even for an entry level data
science interview and the question was
what is an average
[Music]
my name is Alexander Morlock I'm an
educator and speaker at respire IR
machine learning engineering researcher
thyroid scales I love traveling with my
wife I like languages running and I love
good vegan food I'm also working on a
book on causality and python if it's
interested for interesting for you you
can scan this QR code or go to causal
python.io
and with me today is
a mathematician of the PhD from technion
algorithm developer data scientist
loving combining all three areas
together and he loves meeting new people
so do I so if you want to reach out
after the presentation don't be shy and
this is a joint work with not on Katz
our friend from Tel Aviv he's a data
science labor researcher a masters in
physics for investment Institute and he
loves combining theoretical and applied
aspects of machine learning so what
we're going to learn today are free
generalization of the average of an
average I should say
how you can use this generalize the
concept of generalized average for
machine learning projects to make them
better
and in particular how you can make use
of General average in graph neural
networks so our goal today is to give
you all those tools so you can take them
and apply for your projects
and also give you a theoretical
understanding why what we think an
average is
is just like a very special case of what
an average is in general so we want to
try to give her the store also so you
can see the average in all its all its
building and agenda for today we'll
start with the the question what is an
average we'll discuss types of allergies
and their basic properties
then we'll talk about the concept of
General average so we'll talk about some
every a couple of averages and we'll try
to generalize this concept then we will
show how this can be applied for
goodness of fit so for instance when you
joining your model tuning hyper
parameters of your model
then we'll show you a little bit of our
research with graphical networks and
show you how generalized average
operator can make make your models
um better and more quickly summarize so
what is an average and I'm passing the
microphone to Ubi okay what it has
average maybe it's the most simple thing
that everybody knows what is an average
weight
and so we start ask GPT and averages
certain trendency which a way to
describe a set of data and other stuff
that nobody really understand what's
their meaning so
what is it so what does it mean by all
means let's what does it mean being mean
and don't be mean it's okay let's type
of average in junior high Elementary
School we've learned the arithmetic mean
I know my son my son is in eighth grade
and he learned about that in high school
you learn the geometric mean
in calculus you start the harmonic mean
which is the the which is the arithmetic
that one the inverse of the arithmetic
mean of the inverse
and so
this is so there's more than one type of
in average and actually there's 25
and 25 different types 28
and well that's one of us
actually by the end of this lecture that
you know you will know that there's a
Continuum of of averages so this number
25 is a little bit
is too small
okay in ignore the x-axis and let's see
the we took the the harm the harmonic
geometric mean of this array and we see
that the the harmonic is always the the
less one of them the arithmetic is a
maximum and let's see how does is its
scale when we're a little bit playing
with the numbers yes and just I don't
think this gray line is on the bottom
and on the top they are minimum and
maximum of this array right and then in
the in the middle you can see all three
averages as you reset and an important
thing is to ignore the x-axis for for
now okay but you will see that this
makes makes sense and now as you are
proposed let's see what happens when we
increase the variance of this array but
by adding smaller numbers okay so we
took one and we see that the arithmetic
means is about the same the geometric
mean is a little bit now further down
but still stable and the harmonic means
drop down
that's an interesting thing we don't
have the time but if we do it we're at
the variant store and upper we won't see
this phenomena
okay so what is an add General averages
and okay everybody studied calculus they
mean inequality we say that the the map
the
original the average of the aesthetic is
less than the maximum it's more than the
geometric more than harmonic just that
we side more than minimum and
and when and there's equality only in
one case
when the grace that when the array is
fixed
and we know and we know that which is
that all the values in the array are all
the same value yes
okay and now here's our maybe a little
bit something that might be scaring at
first glance but don't be afraid we
defined a function which is called the P
function for all values different than
zero P would be the the piece root of
the arithmetic mean of of all the
elements in the P power and for zero
just would be the geometric mean
and and obviously for positive number
this is we
program it so you see is the code even I
was able to
to Pro to to put it so it's not that
hard each one of you can and see that
this formula
and and things that we got to be careful
first of all it's differential why the
differential as probably all of you know
allows you to coordinate optimization
process and everything is much smoother
and easier than thick the second thing
that we want one strictly positive in
each component uh if it's even strictly
positive in P but it's a different story
and we get that a another interesting a
phenomena that it's it lies between them
the Min but the minimum and the and the
maximum
is if you go to minus infinity you get
the minimum plus infinity the maximum a
minus one harmonic means zero obviously
is a geometric mean and one is the
arithmetic
okay
we can use the weighted averages till
now we didn't mention weighted we'll go
further that but it's a big thing in
machine learning and the second thing
which is important is that if we do re
reordering we get the same values and we
talk in this morning we talked about the
things should be commutative so we get
that
he
he
can we rewrite more can we we wait more
stuff so actually we can we can do it
and there's the layer which is an
American mathematician and and he just
took the a arithmetic mean of the P
power divided by the arithmetic pin uh
mean of the P minus one
and this function is a
uh it's it is a function it is a
agreeing with the law of the previous uh
slide
and is another feature of those means
that we all that was our condition that
everything had to be very easy to
implement because
because otherwise you can get full and
you get full and get too messy and so
everything here is a few lines of code
so don't so if anyone interesting in
using it to your own project don't be
afraid it's easy and fun okay
it's still it is differential which is
good it is a strictly monotone in all
components including a p
and it's agree with the minimum again
then
minimum a
P equals to minus infinity is a minimum
a plus infinity is the
plus infinity is the
plus infinity is the maximum one would
be equals to the arithmetic half is
going to be the geometric and a zero and
zero is going to be the harmonic yeah
and as you can see these are the exactly
the same conditions as we've seen before
for per function so you can see that
although the formulas for name I mean
and for the average were different
they meet the same criteria and the same
conditions so now let's see how this can
be translated to something a little bit
more visual a little bit less abstract
and hopefully they will start getting
into a place where you can see where we
will be able to see how this can be
useful for you in machine learning
projects okay
your favorite your favorite if we're
taking P equals two we're getting the
co-hormone
the co-harmonic means if anyone of you
has done a signal processing it's a it's
it's a it's a mean that people in system
processing love so it's grad related to
that if one you never you never do did
anything like that just just know that
you can take this part into signal
processing that's it a okay
p is a real number from minus infinity
to plus infinity
it moves freely from minimum to maximum
uh it and not its conserved preference
of conservative liberal what does it
mean a conservative wants to be cautious
so he wants to consider the worst case
scenario so he wants to take lower value
and the a liberal would just take would
go for the best case scenario or the
average scenario and so basically you
can choose your liver conservative
liberal preference according to your use
cases in some cases you prefer just
just being good in one aspect and that's
fine and another and you you can screw
it up let's say you were doing the
security sector
you have no room to for any errors and
maybe you're doing algo trading and you
just need to be good in one company and
then you hit the jackpots
and hear how it and here again this
array and the interesting thing that we
plot the P average various the values of
p in the Lerman you can see the S shape
and
we didn't Implement that to say
activation function but this is can be a
nice homework
and and we can see how and we can see
when we change the variance of the array
with the lower value we can see and we
can see that the S is more shape
which is all becomes it becomes more
Steep and also another thing that you
can see here is that label is in general
more steep in both cases right so so
it's it grows faster but also as we can
see as we discussed before the normal
value is never lower than the array and
the maximum value is never higher than
the maximum of the array okay so the so
this property is
um holds here and also you can see how
those lines are crossing the horizontal
lines right so geometric harmonic and
automatic mean you can now see it but
they are just special cases of linear
average and PNP function yeah
and yeah this is exactly and spot and
spot okay so now till now it was a nice
math exercise but we're doing a machine
learning Workshop so we got two and
three uh what is a generalized F1 F1 is
we're taking the harmonic mean a we can
replace with General average because F1
is you probably recall is just the
harmonic mean between The Recoil and
precision
and it can be and everything can be
applied with weight so if you have some
kind of preference you you get it
average and goodness of fit
okay just like we said that this is the
harmonic mean of the Oracle and
precision
and and there's the F beta which is
awaited beta equals to one is the equi
weight
yes
both are generalizations of average in
general and now we are seeing if beta
score which is a generalization of F1
score but by weighting F1 score so
generalization of harmonic mean in
particular yeah
exactly for a large large beta means
that that the
large yeah we will see next slide what
does mean larger beta and North and
North bettas
yeah but in general you can use the F
beta
to analyze your false negatives of false
positives more so for instance if false
positives from your business point of
view or machine learning a project point
of view are most costly for you you can
use this function to penalize them more
on the other hand if if false negatives
are more costly for you you can use the
the same function if with a different
value of beta to penalize them more
okay okay and this is that we optimize
the parameter with different with f beta
and beta equals to three in our case
where it's a a down Precision which
means less false negative if we're
taking low beta it would be vice versa
no problem and this is the graph when
you about the recall and precision to
possible values and we see this is kind
of a reflection of the same graph and
higher beta and close ref to recall
so the higher the beta is the closer you
are to recall regardless if recall is
higher or lower value okay which means
that we always penalize false negatives
harder in this case
and that's why because false negatives
are a part of the wrinkle equation okay
and the horizontal line is F1 score like
traditional F1 score so you can see
again that these lines are crossing at
some point this point is at one
and this shows us that F1 score is a
special case of this F beta score and
actually and you can take one thing
further instead of taking the harmonic
mean just like here you can recall that
the harmonic mean is is a p function
with value P minus one or the layering
manner with value P equals zero so you
can do every all the analysis here with
those two general function which gives
you another degree of freedom to choose
your favorite metric
okay okay beautiful and then
we go to gns yeah
okay so now I I need to ask you for like
a Ultra laser focus because for those of
you who are not familiar with with
graphable networks we'll do like a very
very quick overview uh let me ask you
who's familiar with graph normal
networks who have some experience with
gns okay so a couple of people have
okay good so we will do a quick recap
first
so what about gns now gns or graph
neural networks and neural networks that
operate on graphs
so the name is informative they leverage
graph structural information which means
that when we train a network like this
we don't we do not only look at at the
features of nodes or points or data
points we're also looking
um at their properties structural
properties how they are connected with
with one another okay so maybe
uh in my in my cell phone there
I have always number
okay and this will constitute an edge
between me and Dory what's your name
Matthew I don't have Matthew's number so
we don't have an edge okay we are notes
all notes and only URI and I we are
connected are you connected with Matthew
URI yeah we you are so okay so this is
like a missing Edge uh to form a
triangle so-called good
so now let's imagine this graph we also
have this actually perfectly describes
the situation so I will say that a is me
because I'm Alexander maybe Matthew now
URI is here and Matthew is here right we
have some properties so each of us uh
Matthew Amberley and I we can all be
fully described by just three numbers
surprising maybe but let's assume that's
true
so now
we will say a thing like this
okay A B and C this just says like a is
me on a note with in this in this graph
these Matthew and cease sorry or the
other way around
only in Matthew
and now we want to train a neural
network that will predict something
about this graph
but we want to preserve the structural
information so to do it what we do
is we
take
the information about the node itself
take the information about the neighbor
of this node
and we pass this information through
some function
for now let's say it's an arbitrary
function and we do this for each of the
nodes okay but as you can see for node a
I'm not taking into account the
information from note
from notes from node C
okay it's only nodes A and B for node B
I take information from all of those
nodes because it's neighboring with both
A and C
now an important property of this
function whatever it is is that it is
permutation invariant which means that
if we reverse The Ordering of these
vectors
the output of this function is the same
it doesn't change
so that's the reason why
people use average
and some
in graph neural networks very often
so now when we want at some point we
train this neural network and at some
point we want to get a a graph level
output so maybe we want to predict what
this graph is
or maybe we want to predict a number
that would be called a graph regression
so maybe we want to predict how what is
the total waiting time
on a certain in a certain area of the
city when you have kakima like a traffic
jam okay or maybe we want to predict if
a given protein that is represented as a
graph
belongs to one of five or maybe seven
classes
[Music]
so here is a visualization of a protein
and this is how we can map it to a graph
this is three-dimensional but it doesn't
matter
so an example of a graph level task can
be take a graph
with information about its nodes
[Music]
where the whole graph represents a
protein and you find a label for this
protein so maybe it's a class one for
two of five or seven I don't want to go
into biology
and and how we do it we again use some
function
that Aggregates all of these
representations
and this function also needs to be
exactly the mutation in the variant very
good
and this function is usually called
Global pooling
okay so we're pulling all the
information from the graph and if you
have an association with CNS or computer
vision that's a very good Association
because graphical networks are a
generalization of convolutional neural
networks
so although this might be slightly
different in detail the idea is it's the
same idea
um
what
okay and what we do we take this
representation we pass it through some
um dense layer with soft Max and this is
how we generate a label a prediction
so now we run an experiment we felt like
okay so our generalized average operator
is permutation environment as well
it's not as symmetric as mean is
[Music]
but it's also differentiable so this
parameter P we can put this parameter
into a neural network and optimize it
jointly while learning uh but we're
learning the weights for the
um for the network so we use gcn
architecture we also tried JT but we are
presenting gcn today because it's a
little bit simpler we use proteins data
set which represents proteins as graphs
and for each graph we want to predict a
label we had like five different
treatments which will which was which
were five Global pooling conditions we
used average
sum
Max pooling and two times Lemma mean as
public operator with two different
initializations
so we started with different values of p
in the beginning and then we're
optimizing from that moment
we're on 100 Trans per condition
and
this is how we do it we use tensorflow
and spectral for this
so this is our class Global labor
pooling we use gcn convolutional layers
from spectral and these are the results
so
you can see accuracy here
and we need to say that we were not
optimizing this architecture for very
good results you can get much better
results in general we're just caring for
the comparison of
of The Operators here you have some
operator
here we have average like regular
average this is lamel mean
with initialized with parameter one
which means that we initialized with
regular average because lemon mean with
P1 will give you just like a regular
mean
then we have Lemma with value 10 which
is very close to maximum it's not
maximum but it's very close to maximum
and then we have Max pooling okay so for
each of those representations for free
numbers we are taking Max in each
Dimension we are taking Lemma with P10
for each Dimension average fourth
dimension and sum for each Dimension and
what's important is that some
we know
that Sam gives us a graph neural network
that is the most expressive possible
according to so-called Vice filer Layman
test okay maybe some of you familiar
with this maybe not but this means that
it gives us as far as we know as of
today it gives us the
highest possible theoretical
expressiveness of the network
so let's see this in numbers maybe it
will be a little bit easier to compare
average was giving us
uh the smallest the smallest accuracy
Lama one which was starting from average
and then letting the network optimize
was slightly better maximum was slightly
better than lemur started with parameter
one Sam was very good and lemur started
with parameter 10 close to maximum and
then going down we will see this in a
second was even better than some
but this is very close and you will see
that this result
was not significant statistically
so we were able to match
um so we're able able to match
performance of sample link that is uh
that gives us the highest possible
expressivity with our operator
and do better than anything else and
here you can see this is for
um this is for Lima for for a network
started with Lamer with p-value of of
10. you can see how it was optimized you
can see that it goes down not very much
to 9984 or something like this but it
goes down consistently over over
different trials and you can see this
spikes going up at the end and this
network was trained with
with early stopping which is a strategy
of stopping the training when the
network is overfitting so all those
spikes going up
we're going up like after we had the
optimal after we had the optimal score
okay so this means that this spike is
also indicative of overfitting in the in
the network
challenges and next steps so first thing
we had some challenges with numerical
stability for the P parameter when
training a graph neural network
um we want to try normalizing p in order
to get more efficient optimization
because for now we're just using like
values like 1 and 10 which comparing to
most of the weights that are normalized
somewhere on the way it's a these are
very very high values
and we want to integrate this operator
with spectral which is a graph network
library built on top of tensorflow too
summarizing average can be generalized
in various ways so we've seen freeways
today one was B average another one was
limo mean and another one was F beta
score
generalization can help you achieving
specific results in hyper parameter
tuning so for instance you might
penalize false positives or false
negatives depending on your use case
more using this average
and layer average matches or exceeds the
performance of most popular and most
expressive operators used in gns
nowadays
yes and the main thing between the till
now F beta is kind of a weighted average
that I guess some of you know but it's
mean that you know what to perform your
performance recall or
or a precision and both the lemon and
the p-value you just say what you prefer
minimum and maximum which you have no
prior knowledge which one is going to be
the minimum and the money maximum so
we believe that combination above the
weighted and the the General's average
is going to be very useful in machine
learning and they
go and use it on your way
and your project
will be happy to help you
yeah great thank you so much
and I guess we have five minutes for
questions we have five minutes four
questions so we're very happy to take
your questions if you have any
if the concept of fit forward attention
is not popular in your afternoon
Networks
um
concept of attention in general is very
popular in in rational networks uh fit
forward that was the paper so it's like
a weighted average with the ways that we
learned yeah
yeah so we haven't compared this so far
yeah
does it answer your question
yeah okay I think it's a great
suggestion
[Music]
yeah
and that's a great suggestion so we will
continue the experiments with attention
networks and all the attention yes
[Music]
is it something that you tend to expose
in open sources
uh let's talk sorry because for the
recording so the question was that we've
shown an implementation and Yakov asked
us if we if this is something that we
are willing to open source and you
always said that yes AES actually we do
have already pipe a pie
Library we're working on that and
hopefully it's going to be to your
friends in scikit-learn but they're
doing lots of problems if anyone's to
wants to use that we'll be happy to give
you our own model and just to keep
install it and
and enjoy
yeah so the package is still in beta but
we'll uh we'll be announcing this soon
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]